Given these two dags, which both compute
reductions, which one is better?
Now, the linear dag has a sequential
chain of dependencies, so it can never
really use more than one processor
at a time, other than the loads.
The tree, by contrast can use
parallelism at every level.
So the sequential dag will take On time,
where the tree-based dag
will take log n time.
Now, intuitively, if I give you two dags
and they both compute the same thing,
than you generally prefer the one
that has more parallelism.
But is that the only
thing you care about?
Does anything else matter?
I'm going to walk you through
a formalism called work span analysis.
It will help you answer these and
a number of other interesting questions.
Given a dag like this one, I will
always ask you two questions about it.
The first questions is,
how many vertices does it have in total?
And I'm going to give this a name.
And I'm going to call it work.
And I'll usually write it as W of n,
since the total
number of operations should somehow
depend on the size of the input n.
Now computing the work is easy,
you just count the number of vertices.
The second thing I'll ask
you about a dag always,
is how long is the longest
path through the dag?
This also has a special name,
I'm going to call it the span.
And I'm going to use the symbol
D of n to represent the span.
Now in this dag, here is the longest
path, which I've circled, and
this path also has a special name.
It's called the critical path.
Now as a historical aside,
the length of this critical path or
what I just called the span,
historically was called depth.
And that's why I'm using
the symbol D of n.
Back in my day, we didn't have no span.
We called it depth, and you liked it.
So, in terms of work and span,
can we now say something about
the time to execute the dag
on a PRAM with p processors?
Here's some simple things we can say.
First, if all the operations have unit
cost, then the time to execute this
dag using only one processor
should be exactly the work W of n.
Now let's consider the other scenario.
Suppose I give you an infinite
number of processors.
What's the time?
Well if you have an infinite number of
processors it really doesn't matter,
because you still have to
execute the critical path and
that has length T of n.
So the time given an infinite
number of processors is D of n.
So, those are two handy facts, but
I think we want to try to say more.